pour soir nous sommes le 3 juillet les
18 heures pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
en direct leurs du 7-8 lecture sur
téléphiles voici les principaux titres à
l'open de golf alstom vient de s'ouvrir
à saint quentin en yvelines
nous verrons comment se passe le début
de cette édition le secrétaire d'état
aux sports était lui aussi présent sur
le gréement un nouveau rythme scolaire
réforme des programmes l'éducation reste
un sujet qui fâche l'année scolaire à
peine terminée nous parlerons de la
rentrée avec le directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale b
zibeline jean michel poignard est
l'invité de ce jour d'hui et puis le
temps d'un stage proposé par
l'association art en tête l'abbaye de
port royal des champs vous propose de
devenir tailleur de pierre cette semaine
un nouveau mécène pour la nouvelle école
sciences po saint germain en laye le
crédit agricole vient d'apporter un
soutien de 450 millions d'euros 450
mille euros sur trois ans à l'institut
d'études politiques est cet argent doit
permettre de développer le programme de
démocratisation certains jeunes pourront
bénéficier d'un dégrèvement ou d'une
exemption des frais de scolarité d'une
bourse d'étude ou d'un dispositif de
préparation au concours d'entrée
sciences po saint germain qui ouvrira en
septembre avec 80 élèves
le projet est porté par les universités
de cergy pontoise et de versailles saint
quentin 10 sport l'open de golf alstom
c'est parti depuis ce matin sur le green
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette
édition annoncée plus facile en raison
d'un parcours de l'albatros revue dans
le cadre de la préparation de la ryder
cup en 2018 devrait aussi être plus
spectaculaire cette année selon les
spécialistes les promesses sont elles
tenues après une première journée de
compétition nous allons voir avec
anthony rech
de mémoire de golfeurs lors d'un premier
tour on avait rarement vu autant de
monde autour du départ du trou numéro 1
de l'albatros personne ne veut louper
l'entrée en lice du numéro un français à
commencer par le secrétaire d'état aux
sports en visite au golf national
contrairement à d'autre part je pense au
tennis
lorsqu'un grand tournoi on sait que ces
trois ou quatre joueurs qui peuvent
gagner là à chaque fois sans mais une
vingtaine dans les vins est toujours des
français c'est vrai que cette année tout
le monde met la pression sur victor
dubuisson
il a quatre jours pour bien peu tes pas
faire d'erreurs et on sera derrière lui
bien sûr pour ce premier tour victor
dubuisson va affronter l'albatros aux
côtés de deux grands favoris
le tenant du titre graeme mcdowell est
le favori allemand martin kaymer récent
vainqueur de l'us open
mais ce que personne n'osait croire
arrive dès le premier drive le 22e
joueur mondial sera complètement et
envoie sa balle hors du fairway
après deux trous il se retrouve même à
quatre coups du par bon il vient ici en
favori quoi avait tout tout le public
qui le porte et je pense que ça ya mis
un petit peu de la pression oui je vais
des très grands joueurs donc ça va le
tirer vers le haut et ça le stimule et
je pense qu'il ya un gros mental il va
remettre revient dans la partie très
vite
comme attendu le numéro un français
réagit avec un premier birdie au trou
numéro 9
mais visiblement agacé par son manque de
réussite
il concède un nouveau bogeys aux 13 pour
se retrouver à cinq coups du par lot de
consolation côté français le jeune
alexander levy 23 ans pour un
provisoirement à la 7e place et en marge
de la compétition thierry braillard vous
l'avez vu le secrétaire d'état aux
sports est venu sur ce parcours de
l'open rencontrer les sportifs et
surtout rappelé le soutien de l'état en
vue de l'organisation de la ryder cup
sur ce site à la compétition qui oppose
je vous le rappelle les meilleurs
européens aux meilleurs américains se
déroulera en 2018 à saint quentin en
yvelines
olivier maniscalco premier jour de
compétition à l'open de france sur le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour ce tournoi majeur sur le
circuit européen les élus locaux et
français ont fait le déplacement
notamment thierry braillard secrétaire
d'état chargée des sports qui peut
compter sur jean van de velde anciens
pros et directeur du tournoi pour lui
expliquer l'effet rétro de la balle de
golf
coincé entre la base s'est rassuré outre
l'open de france l'autre sujet de
discussion c'est 2018 et le golf
national de saint-quentin qui
accueillera la célèbre ryder cup
alors forcément avec la venue du
secrétaire d'état les élus locaux
attendent des réponses notamment sur le
financement d'un tel événement
l'engagement de l'état vous savez moi
j'ai suivi d'autres opérations notamment
le vélodrome et bien il a fallu que
chaque fois qu'un nouveau ministre
arrive est retourné dans le bureau du
ministre pour que l'état à nouveau nous
a confirmé donc moi je suis comme saint
thomas je ne crois que ce que je vois je
ne crois que ce que j'entends et les
engagements des uns
j'espère que sont ils seront respectés
par les autres à l'état va soutenir et
soutient déjà et va soutenir la ryder
cup je crois que si on ne peut pas avoir
plus belle exposition a laissé bien que
ce s'accompagnera la politique que je
vous disais de popularisation le golf
aujourd'hui est quasiment un des sports
les plus pratiqués en france
qui aurait dit ça il ya
vingt ans je pense qu'il faut continuer
en attendant la ryder cup les élus ont
pu assister au départ mitigé de victor
dubuisson numéro un français qui
comptait déjà quatre uccle au dessus du
par après deux trous l'open de golf se
poursuit jusqu'à dimanche du sport à
l'économie la maison de l'entreprise de
saint quentin en yvelines a dressé son
bilan et définir ses priorités en
présence de ses partenaires piloté par
la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin
elle devrait logiquement prendre de
nouvelles orientations avec l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle équipe politique à sa
tête suite aux élections municipales
clair tant bien la maison de
l'entreprise a dressé son bilan hier en
compagnie de ses partenaires
cet outil créé par la communauté
d'agglomération contribuer au
développement économique du territoire
parmi leurs actions des rendez vous avec
des créateurs des permanences d'experts
des visites d'entreprises mais surtout
en accompagnement des porteurs de
projets sur l'année 2013-2014
la maison de l'entreprise a accompagné
720 projet soit 3700 heures de conseil
elle a ainsi permis la création de 300
entreprises avec ses partenaires
les acteurs économiques publics et
privés du territoire elle cherche à
aller encore plus loin
l'association delta sky a par exemple
proposé de créer un incubateur
il faut pas qu'elle paris aspire tout il
faut aussi que les autres territoires
puissent avoir leur propre incubateur
alors sans concurrence mais en
complémentarité des cas des projets un
peu plus industrielles il faut aller
mettre ces entreprises au plus près des
industriels qui vont être leurs clients
donc des incubateurs dans des
territoires de première ou seconde
couronne parisienne sont idéalement
placés pour ça car à l'accent sera porté
l'année prochaine sur l'innovation
notamment pour favoriser l'emploi on a
tout intérêt nous en tant qu'appui
collectivités appuyé le public à
favoriser la création on va dire à haut
niveau pour ensuite décliné des emplois
qui pourraient se développer sur le
territoire donc ça c'est une première
démarche
et puis on a beaucoup parlé aussi des
entreprises en
pour cela la plateforme initiative a mis
en place des prêts conjoncturelle
d'autres projets sont à l'étude
le possible élargissement de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pourrait
également redessiné le champ
d'intervention de la maison de
l'entreprise et envisager l'intégration
de maurepas et coignard d'un côté et
plaisir villepreux et les
clayes-sous-bois de l'autre décision
prise en janvier 2015 nouveau rythme
scolaire un nouveau programme
suppression des notes égalité des sexes
chaque semaine des annonces autour de
l'éducation sont faites à la veille de
ses vacances scolaires nous allons faire
un point avec lequel jean michel
coignard directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale dans
les yvelines bonsoir mon revenu en
plateau l'année et touche à sa fin quel
bilan faites-vous les choses ont été
compliquées notamment pour lancer les
nouveaux rythmes scolaires mais c'est
bon c'est sur les rails
c'est sur les rails les rythmes
scolaires ce n'est pas une chose facile
sa demande avait communauté scolaire
partout sur le territoire de s'entendre
sur de nouveaux rythme pour les enfants
la situation rapidement brossé ses 240
communes avec école 8 qui avait commencé
cette année donc il continue mais parmi
lesquels quatre change de modèle or on
voit que il faut s'attendre à des
modifications en cours de route
et puis toutes les autres qui ont un
projet est très peu qui ont un projet
que je leur est imposée par manque de
décision de leur part une poignée de
communes qui ne sont pas du tout les
appliquer et vous avez posées elles sont
elles sont quelques-unes
il en reste quatre avec lesquels nous
continuons à discuter ces quatre
communes sont alors oui il faut que
jamais les lunettes
ce sont de petites communes puisque le
rural pose davantage de difficultés mais
qui sonne et sur l'organisation que ça
leur pose problème que sur l'idée même
de mettre en place la réforme des
rythmes voilà alors c'est délicat parce
qu'en fait également les équipes
municipales ont pu changer
donc il ya parmi celles que je vais
citer des communes qui avaient un projet
la nouvelle multiplie les municipalités
ne veux pas le mettre en route et ils
sont pas encore au stade où on en met en
place à la rentrée
alors que nous nous savons ce qu'il
convient de faire et nous leur avons dit
donc voilà on discute encore un peu ces
communes sont orphelins richebourg
guîtres en cours et drocourt ourliac ce
sont de petites communes qui de communes
qui n'ont pas encore de projet mais ça
viendra
dc dc forcément là si quelques années
les communes en tout cas même celles qui
s'opposaient sur le fond même de la
réforme et sur l'idée de mettre en place
des nouveaux rythmes scolaires sont bien
obligés de proposer une organisation du
temps seulement l'organisation même ce
qui sera fait pendant sept et apc temps
d'activité supplémentaire ça ça reste
libre à chaque commune un programme d
une commune c'est un petit peu de la
garderie alors ça c'est très divers lors
d'une part les compétences sont bien
distinctes
nous nous avons la partie purement c'est
l'immense colère donc là déjà ça nous
cause pas mal de modifications puisqu'il
faudra apprendre à travailler avec les
enfants notamment essentiellement le
mercredi matin donc changement d'emploi
du temps et pour les communes
sa demande a modifier ce qui était fait
dans le périscolaire jusque là ont
changé certains horaires et donc chaque
municipalité a le pouvoir de voir ce qui
sera offert aux devoirs dans certaines
communes
une fonction de l'organisation du temps
ça ne va durer quelques fois qu'une demi
heure voire un quart d'heure et qu'au
final ce sera de la garderie n'y aura
pas d'activité sont proposés aux enfants
on peut pas raisonner aussi globalement
ce qui les communes qui le disent
clairement
on s'adapte au rythme scolaire on est
contre on le fait mais on le fait juste
parce qu il faut s adapter aux panneaux
après peu importe car adam sept ans oui
mais elles disent aussi avec un esprit
de responsabilité qu'elles ne prendront
pas les enfants en otage et elle dit
aussi qu'elle compte offrir un service
de qualité à la population
donc vous reçoit de contrôle dessus
amano après sept ans comme nous n'ont
pas en revanche ce qui est fait de
revanche j'y ai dit partout et je
demande à ce que les comités de suivi de
mise en place de ces nouveaux rythmes
dans chaque commune continue à se réunir
puisqu'ils font un lieu des changes
en effet alors je vous donne un exemple
on voit apparaître le midi un quart
d'heure de tap
évidemment vu comme ça ça n'a pas de
sens on se demande ce qu'on peut faire
un quart d'heure et aurait invité la
réflexion peut se poursuivre sur une
coupure qui étaient d'une heure et demie
seulement le midi par exemple et qui
passe à l'honneur trois quarts c'est pas
le quart d'heure là c'est le fait qu'on
ait une heure trois quarts le midi
hélas si vous ajoutez les questions de
restauration scolaire avec plusieurs
services et les activités d'animation
qui étaient déjà mises en place vous
avez de quoi améliorer
voilà donc je ne voudrais pas qu'on
reste reine ces questions bien que je ne
sois pas chaud pas compétent pour les
traiter à seulement des morceaux de
temps au contraire c'est l'ensemble la
journée qu'il faut revoir et y compris
vous dites certaines communes n'offrent
rien de plus mais rien de plus elle
offrait déjà quelque chose que je sache
il ya des études ou des aides aux
devoirs scolaires pour son cadre de
plaisir qui a dit mettre en place une
récré amont justement ça vous fait
sourire justement un rapport au ministre
c'était un clin d'oeil de la mer qui a
décidé de rajouter un temps de deux
gardes supplémentaires jusqu'à 16h30
pour permettre au projet croit savoir
que l'on continue à discuter au sein de
la commune que récemment les parents ont
été reçus et qu'en réalité va se mettre
petit à petit en place quelque chose qui
ne sera pas exclusivement la création et
attention aux idées reçues les enfants
dont dans une journée non pas que besoin
d'avoir un emploi du temps de ministre
justement il leur faut des temps de
repos des temps de jeu des temps
l'activité physique
alors ce n'est pas de la garderie mais
c'est autre chose que des supers
seulement activité nouvelle qui
arriverait un bilan ses rythmes
scolaires le fouet ce week-end pour voir
à pas en fin d'année prochaine et sert
l'expérience de cette année nous montre
que entre novembre et décembre donc on a
l'expérience jusqu'à tous tout simple on
regarde la remise en route de toussaint
et puis à mi parcours avant noël là il
faut faire un point je rappelle que l'an
dernier certaines communes ont modifié
ce qu'elle faisait et nous aussi
d'ailleurs
à la rentrée de janvier donc c'est tout
à fait rien exiger ça peut encore
évoluer en fonction bien évidemment des
enfants que d'ailleurs je ne peux rien
vous cacher ses ouailles évolue encore
en ce moment dans certaines communes
hier encore des changements absolument
qu'on demande aux parents d'être guerre
forcément à vigilants attentifs à ce
qu'ils savent c'est quelque chose qui se
construit en commun vont chaque
interlocuteur au représentant
d'interlocuteurs sait très bien qu'ils
ne peut pas tout avoir
l'idéal n'est pas décrété en revanche on
peut construire pas à pas quelque chose
de plus intéressant pour le tour des
enfants
on va mettre de côté les rythmes
scolaires mais on va continuer à parler
de changement réflexion autour des
programmes par exemple c'est assez
régulier les changements dans
l'éducation nationale pourquoi à tout
prix vouloir tout refaire est ce
vraiment une bonne idée nous avons posé
la question aujourd'hui dans les rues de
50 ans est notre question du jour
moi personnellement je préférais gardé
mercredi matin les enfants pouvaient se
reposer le matin ça a été fait un peu
dans la rapidité et sans vraiment
concertation non ça me semble pas être
bonne réforme
mais bon pourquoi pas voir sur le long
terme et va a priori non ça me paraît
bien fade
je pense que c'est difficile aussi pour
les animateurs pour vraiment faire leur
travail contre correctement parce que le
fait d'avoir des mercredis complet ça
leur permet quand même de faire des
vraies activités de mettre en place des
vraies de vraies choses le mercredi ne
me dérangeait pas puisque j'ai des
grands scolarisés déjà mercredi
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas quelque
chose qui pourrait poser problème et en
plus je ne travaille pas ça sert à rien
parce que ils déplacent les heures pour
remettre sur mercredi ça sert à rien on
leur enlève des heures dans la semaine
pour leur remettre sur mercredi pour
faire le même nombre d'heures où est
l'intérêt
ce sont les rythmes scolaires qui
préoccupe
les parents je vais peut-être vous
laisser répondre à ce qui a été dit sur
l'année dernière c'est bien normal mais
ça ne sert à rien ne sert à rien c'est
justement c'est un des fondements de
cette de cette évolution de cette
réforme c'est que la distribution du
temps d'apprentissage est importante
pour l'efficacité de des enseignements 5
matin ça le changement 5 matin c'est
mieux que des heures l'après midi du
point de vue même des enseignants quand
on regarde la capacité à des élèves de
se concentrer sur des tâches scolaires
donc non ça n'a pas ce n'est pas sans
effet le nombre d'heures elle-même la
distribution on trouvera une nouvelle
fois avec cette réforme qu'elle est
essentielle pour les apprentissages des
élèves
et n'oublions pas que si on parle on ne
les ont pas que le but de tout ça ce
sont certes des rythmes sur la semaine
des enfants mais c'est d'essayer de
faire en sorte qu'à l'arrivée le socle
les programmes qu'elle arrivait en fin
de cursus à l'issue de la troisième les
connaissances les compétences des jeunes
soient meilleurs que ce qu'on nous
montre les évaluations internationales
c'est ça le but connaissances
compétences on peut peut-être parler des
programmes aussi fin décembre 2013
l'ancien ministre maintenant vincent
peillon qui présentait ses orientations
pour les futurs programmes de la
maternelle au collège et le changement
de ministre ce n'est pas une nouveauté
on en est aujourd'hui de cette volonté
de changer les programmes ça avance
toujours les consultations étaient
légèrement différée elles auront lieu à
notre connaissance dans le premier
trimestre de l'année scolaire prochaine
certes comme je reconnais dans le
reportage
donc c'est vrai ça revient souvent ça
revient souvent mais c'est important
parce que pour les enseignants c'est un
mode d'appropriation dossier est
essentiel dans les cursus dans les
curricula on dit aujourd'hui cirque est
ce qu'il faut retenir de prioritaire sur
les grandes compétences et connaissances
pour les élèves
donc voilà maintenant la mise en oeuvre
nous l'annoncent pour 2016 à présent et
s'est accompagnée d'une réflexion sur le
socle qui est leur repère le plus
partagé possible dans toute la france de
ce qu'on doit savoir précisément ce 23e
et la façon de l'évaluer également parce
que l'idée a été lancée par benoît hamon
pourrait supprimer les notes par exemple
ce serait une bonne idée
mais ça existe déjà figurez vous que
certaines écoles ont eu une longue
habitude un dans le primaire dans les
écoles primaires on allait livret de
compétences depuis les années 90 dans la
nouveauté c'est que sur le collège
on voit fleurir des expériences de
classe sans notes pour faire une
confidence monfils est en sixième italie
2 dans une sixième sens note car tant
que parent ça ne vous gêne pas de ne pas
voir de notes pourrait évaluer votre
enfant non il faut interroger les profs
et les parents les professeurs qui
essaya cette année je pense l'exemple
vient d'une quarantaine dans les
yvelines dont les collèges disent que ça
les forces vont appeler les bulletins il
existe toujours et là y'a plus de notes
salées force à libeller des
appréciations sur ce que savent plus
précisément ou ne savent pas encore les
élèves et ça plus précis sont ils pour
cannes note parce que c'est l'industrie
ça exige un hylan empêche pas l'autre
mais en tout cas il faut se rappeler que
un élève est dans une démarche longue
on veut qu'à la fin ils sachent des
choses il faut lui donner confiance dans
ce qu'il a déjà acquis pour qu'il
franchit cette étape suivante la note
seul me semble-t-il ne suffit pas c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi il y avait déjà des
appréciations dans les bulletins par les
voir aussi cette année on revient sur
ses libations plusieurs faux s'ils
voulaient en fait c'est la même chose un
peu on a des programmes qui fixe des
contenus on va dire pour simplifier et
de l'autre côté on voudrait mobilisés
sur le regard du point de vue d'élèves
c'est à dire qu'est ce que je sais faire
qu'est ce que j'ai appris c'est ça les
compétences seul le regard croisé nous
permettra de le faire petit à petit mois
beaucoup de chantiers l'année prochaine
ça manque pas et je peux donner un signe
positif pour la montrer à ça intéresse
tout le tout le département
il se confirme que nous avons plus
d'élèves donc il est rappelé aux
enseignants donc on n'aura plus
enseignants ça c'est sûr alors pas moins
d'enseignants on sait déjà que davantage
mais surtout la démographie scolaire du
département est positive dès la
maternelle
jusqu'au lit et on aura l'occasion bien
sûr en septembre de revenir sur ces
chiffres plus précis de la rentrée
scolaire il est tout de même dans
l'actualité aujourd'hui la publication
par l'insee d'une enquête plus d'une
personne sur dix travaillant à
l'éducation nationale qui déclare avoir
fait l'objet de menaces et d'insultés
c'est plus que dans les autres
professions c'est forcément inquiétant
ne serait ce que pour les nouveaux
enseignants qui vont arriver pour les
rassurer avant qu'ils prennent leurs
fonctions dans les classes quel va être
le mot d'ordre avec des questions
nationales c'est une vraie préoccupation
déjà il faut le dire
là on a quelque chose d'un peu
scientifique qui nous donne un miroir
mois au quotidien je peux dire que
augmente chaque année les situations
particulières où les agressions sont là
le ton monte
que ce soit relatif d'ailleurs à des
eaux services rendus donc là ça concerne
par enseignant ou relatif et des
situations d'élèves pour lesquels bas il
ya désaccord les élèves ou s'est tendue
c'est plutôt collèges lycées lorsque
c'est les parents avec qui s'est
compliquée avec les enseignants l'étude
montré que c'était plus dans les écoles
malheureusement maternelle douala
heureusement les signes de préoccupation
sont sur le sur le primaire c'est là je
vois le plus d'augmentation alors les
réponses
il faut absolument épauler les
enseignants en termes de formation parce
que il faut savoir réagir il faut savoir
nul par exemple piloter des réunions de
manière nouvelle
voir fréquemment les parents et puis il
faut qu'on ait de la communication plus
importante vers les parents c'est quand
on est plus clair depuis l'institution
scolaire envers les parents et façon
régulière qu'on évite des crispations
qui sont le plus souvent le résultat de
malentendus qui sont installés mais
forcément à vouloir aussi on en revient
à la réforme à vouloir tout changer
changer les rythmes changer les
programmes supprimer ou non
les notes ça crée des tensions aussi les
parents qui sont peut-être quelques fois
un peu perdu et du coup l'enseignant est
en première ligne vu en négatif ça peut
être le propos mais en renversant la
perspective ça donne justement les
occasions de se recomposer ensemble sur
des sujets qui sont importants pour tout
le monde parce que nous nous sommes les
adultes on est en train de parler des
enfants qui apprennent donc il faut
susciter les lieux de débat et de
dialogue
je reprends l'exemple de la note parce
que ses caractéristiques
1 un parent d'élève qui a aidé son
enfant comme il l'a pu le soir par
exemple en mathématiques et qui voit au
fil des bulletins 4 sur 20 mauvaise
élève ni pour les lèvres je pense ni
pour le parent qui essayait de faire
s'ils pouvaient ni pour le professeur
satisfaisant voyez donc ça faut en
parler et donc on a des sujets c'est
vrai des vrais gros sujet l'évaluation
la relation famille les rythmes des
enfants qui doivent nous permettre de
positiver et de davantage s'ouvrir à
l'extérieur pour expliquer les débats et
ses enjeux donc beaucoup de chantiers
beaucoup d'enjeu pour cette rentrée
vous aurez l'occasion bien sûr de
revenir en plateau pour en parler merci
à jean michel coignard directeur
académique des services de l'éducation
nationale dans le département
et si vous venez de nous rejoindre
l'intégralité de cet entretien comme les
autres tout au long de la semaine sont à
revoir sur notre site internet
équitation à présent le haras de la
cense accueilli une nouvelle étape du
master ibérique une compétition de
dressage réservée aux chevaux pur-sang
portugais est plus race espagnole 4 andy
la tôle à 10 mois ils ont l'alluré fière
des andalous au son des guitares ses
chevaux lusitaniens espagnols sont dans
leur élément
une allure altière qui tient bien le pas
de côté et ce n'est pas un hasard car
ces équidés développent leurs propres
aptitudes
ils ont des allures un peu différent des
chevaux hollandais ou allemands qui ont
peut-être des allures plus développés
disant qu' ils ont plus de facilité à
l'est sur les côtés que c'est show
torride appréhension
c'est chaud là sont destinés normalement
la corrida au départ c'était les chevaux
de guerre
il était fait pour les régler après il a
évolué pour s'occuper des troupeaux qui
ensuite la corrida ce master ibérique
était donc construit spécialement pour
eux plusieurs concours en espagne italie
portugal et belgique avec une étape en
france dans les yvelines pour une
épreuve de dressage seul et unique
rendez-vous en ile de france parmi les
cavaliers jean-claude avril etc est un
des gars chaud ils sont partenaires
depuis six ans
la qualité des briques c'est que c'est
un cheval qui est très très près de
l'homme c'est la sélection qu'on a voulu
à l'origine
et donc c'est un cheval qui aime l'homme
qui aime être avec lui et qui était
d'une générosité
j'allais dire exceptionnelle leurs
qualités physiques c'est bon j'ai à dire
c'est le mental un mental quand même
souvent à toute épreuve
ces masters du cheval ibérique sont
qualificatifs pour le championnat
d'europe qui se déroulera dans quelques
mois en france
cette semaine l'association l'art en
tête organise un stage de sculpture aux
granges de l'abbaye de port royal des
champs huit stagiaires se sont déjà
aventuré dans le taillage de pierre un
reportage de mathilde qu'à berne et de
juliette tous sont josette est à son
quatrième stage de sculpture
elle s'inspire cette fois ci d'une
statue d'un sculpteur peu connu devenue
experte du burin et du marteau elle
tente malgré tout de définir les
qualités nécessaires pour tailler la
pierre peut être un petit sens
artistique c'est vrai que la dimension
en 3d on n'y est pas très habitués on
peut dessiner on peut vous voir vos
beaucoup d'image on est un siècle
d'image mais le 3d c'est voir à la fois
vu du au vu de derrière et c'est puis
que tout soit soit plausible en quelque
sorte un travail qui demande du temps
une bonne semaine pour finir cette
statue pas besoin d'être un
professionnel pour participer à l'un de
ces stages c'est avant tout un moment de
convivialité et de rencontre n'est pas
seulement
c'est un temps où il se met à parler
laissent leurs activités pour venir
sculpté c'est nous c'est aussi
un loisir de réalisation de soi de
sculpter puisse et pérenne une sculpture
bon lâché soir où la garde longtemps
plat mètres à l'extérieur et c'est sans
doute ce que ça plaît vendredi 5 juillet
les apprentis sculpteurs exposeront
leurs oeuvres aux granges de port royal
des champs à magny les hameaux
merci de nous avoir suivi le journal
revient demain vendredi aux mêmes
horaires ce jeudi soir vous avez rendez
vous avec file echo proposé par claire
cambier bonne soirée